how long you been down here few
months you like the
weather heat is nice though humidity not
not as much I can see
that all right I think you're good to
go
[Music]
hey hey man hi it's uh it's good to
connect you too great to be here excited
glad you are listen I uh I want to get
right to it from what I'm hearing you
guys are are
bankrupt no what no cuz the word on the
street is that you're you're Dr drowning
no that's that's crazy we're we're doing
great you're on the record with that
obviously all right man well then we're
going to get the live feed up right now
and then we're going to get to you right
after this next advertising break
perfect great yes can't
wait all right one more spot and then
you're going to be up I I really do
think this is the right time for you to
communicate great yes address it all
head on it's going to it's going to be
good
no come on gabee we're on in 10 seconds
I can't do this I'm sorry seriously bye
I'm ter sorry we're going on right
now
hey what's the
damage
let me guess you need cash didn't call
Ken first did you he had Philips reach
out how much did he
offer I haven't them back yet well how
much do you need you know what don't
answer that the number doesn't matter
whatever it is I'd love to buy in tell
Ken to fill in the rest
prick hey Ken hey hi um so I might
need
uh a new investor consider it done just
keep moving forward don't think about
what Grandpa Melvin used to say
prick thank you both Citadel and 72 have
infused $3 billion into Melvin Capital
to try
to bail out can you believe this crap
nobody bailed me out when Richard left
me alone with two toddlers a mortgage
car that never works but we it's just so
damn unfair and you know it all we've
done for the last year is work our asses
off helping people and all we've gotten
is$ $600 check this idiot FS up just
about as bad as anyone can f and his
friends come running in with three
billion dollar that's why I keep telling
you you're never going to win just take
the money and do something nice pay off
your mortgage get that one
braces look who's still
holding if he's in I'm in yeah he's
still going to need braces your teeth
are perfect so what the Stock's up $150
how much higher is it going to go we
control the price now not Wall Street
and no one on there is selling shoes
you're all so delusional maybe but look
at what we managed to do with these
hedge funds if we keep driving up the
price maybe we'll scare more of these
guys into closing out their shorts and
then all of that bailout money becomes
ours your screen name is ston
[Music]
Mom hey help your mother want me a not
just shut up and do it okay ke take the
potato you're all rich now there the 23
million on paper but I won't Kevin L
says what what Kevin
[Music]
let tell us
what oh uh I was waiting to tell you in
person but the uh stock we bet on
GameStop is up ah
good how much up he's up 23 million pop
give an [__] don't kid us uh it's
it's real yeah it's real and he's
refusing to sell
what is going on you pulling our leg no
your son's a huge internet celebrity now
millions of people including ston mom
thinks he's some like I don't know
investment genius no he is a genius no
he's not you're up 23
million and you're not
selling Jesus Mary and Joseph what the
is wrong with you do you even know how
much $23 million is and you're just
going to let it ride what's the matter
with you I know what I'm doing why
aren't you selling what wait is this
illegal are you in trouble no no he's
not in trouble it's totally legal he's
posting his balance sheet on the
internet hedge fund managers they go on
CNBC all the time to pump up the stock
all I do is post my balance sheet on
Wall Street bets after market closed you
post your balance sheet yeah the same
idiot who left the fresh pair of Nikes
out in the bleaches for just anyone to
take so you admit they were stolen I
Adit at least I won the race what's the
point of winning the race if you let
some dip steal the prize you would have
broke a four if you have the zoom four
minute mile is in everything maybe we
should get in touch with briggie you
know he works in finance you think
briggsy knows more about this than Keith
does well can you talk about why you're
putting your stocks in the Wall Street
Journal Wall Street bets what if
somebody tries to rob you kidnap the
baby no one's going to kidnap the baby
nobody wants that baby I'm just saying
that if we're going to talk to somebody
you need to talk to briggsy this is
enough you guys Keith has literally
poured his heart and his soul into this
for the past year he knows what he's
doing you know it's been a tough time of
life
you should still
sell think you should
sell now you carotic cells I'm just
principle of the whole thing I don't
like it any more than you do are cells
that have a lot of
organes or tiny little factories for
instance
the nucleus the
mitochondria now eukariotic cells are
typically you really don't think that
he's
ladies
masks kids are with their father for a
few days so I'm going to Florida you
finally sold huah no I'm putting it on
my Visa you shoting me you're worth
hundreds of thousands of dollars in
stock and you're a messing credit card
debt you really are out of your mind no
babe I am all in Diamond hand did you
know that Gabe Plotkin gave an interview
where he's been getting death threats
and antisemitic messages from these WSB
guys 10 comments there's always bad
apples and the moderators deleted it
right away you're just going to ride
this thing till zero no I'm buying call
options they can go to 600 byal the kid
is never getting
braces